It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans start at $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在正值盛花期，我的业务正飞速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢喧闹，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐起价仅为 35 美元/月。这绝对是一个不会长久的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。需另付税费和政府规费。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. You know those people who always seem to be happy, who go through life seeing the sunny side of every situation, or who seem to be at peace and content, even when facing challenging times? Do you ever wonder what is their secret? Today we're going to talk to a psychologist who has spent decades studying the science of happiness about how much of our own happiness is within our control and what we can do to become happier. Some of the questions we'll discuss what actually makes us happy, what habits or minds, sets make the biggest difference. Why don't success and money always lead to lasting satisfaction? And is the modern world of technology and social media making us less happy as many people worry?
Google Fi Wireless 不会在网络高流量期间遭受数据流量降速。你认识那些似乎总是很高兴、在生活中能看到每种情况阳光一面、或者似乎平静且满足（即使面对充满挑战的时期）的人吗？你有没有想过他们的秘密是什么？今天，我们将与一位花了几十年研究幸福科学的心理学家讨论，我们自己的幸福有多少在我们的掌控之中，以及我们可以做些什么来变得更快乐。我们将讨论的一些问题包括：是什么真正让我们快乐？哪些习惯或心态会带来最大的改变？为什么成功和金钱并不总能带来持久的满足感？正如许多人所担忧的那样，现代科技和社交媒体世界是否真的在让我们变得不那么快乐？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Sonia Lubomerski, a distinguished professor of psychology at the University of California Riverside, where she studies what makes people happy and how happiness can shift over time. She's won many awards, including fellow status from three different scientific societies, an honorary doctorate from the University of Basel and a Templeton Positive Psychology Prize. Her work has been funded by grants from the John Templeton Foundation and the National Institutes of Health, among others. She's also the author of two best-selling books, the How of Happiness and the Myths of Happiness,
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是加州大学河滨分校（University of California Riverside）的心理学杰出教授索尼娅·柳博米尔斯基（Dr. Sonia Lyubomirsky），她专门研究是什么让人类快乐，以及幸福感如何随时间推移而改变。她曾获得多项荣誉，包括来自三个不同科学协会的院士身份、巴塞尔大学（University of Basel）的名誉博士学位以及坦普尔顿积极心理学奖（Templeton Positive Psychology Prize）。她的工作得到了约翰·坦普尔顿基金会（John Templeton Foundation）和美国国立卫生研究院（National Institutes of Health）等机构的资助。她还是两本畅销书的作者，分别是《幸福的决定因素》（The How of Happiness）和《幸福的迷思》（The Myths of Happiness），
and she recently began publishing a newsletter called The Happiness Files. Dr. Libar Murski, thank you for joining me today. It's a pleasure to be here, Kim. Thank you. Well, let's start by talking about a question I posed in the introduction, which is how much of happiness is really within our control. In your book, The How of Happiness, from 2008, you estimated that about 50% of our happiness level is due to genes, 10% is due to life circumstances,
她最近开始出版一份名为《幸福档案》（The Happiness Files）的时事通讯。柳博米尔斯基博士，非常感谢您今天能来。很高兴能来到这里，金。谢谢你。那么，让我们从我在引言中提出的一个问题开始，即幸福到底有多少是在我们的掌控之中的。在您 2008 年出版的书中，您估计我们幸福水平的大约 50% 是由基因决定的，10% 是由生活环境决定的，
and about 40% to factors we can control. Do you still think that's about right? No, and I really never did. I think that that pie chart theory of happiness has been widely misinterpreted, although maybe it's my fault. Those numbers were really meant to be very, very not set in stone, and they were based on data that we had at the time in the early 2000s. And I actually were an article with my co-author, Ken Sheldon,
大约 40% 是由我们可以控制的因素决定的。您现在还认为这个比例大致正确吗？不，其实我从来没有这么认为过。我认为那个幸福饼图理论被广泛误解了，尽管这可能是我的错。那些数字本来就不是一成不变的，它们是基于我们在 2000 年代初期拥有的数据得出的。我和我的合著者肯·谢尔顿（Ken Sheldon）实际上写过一篇文章，
kind of revisiting the pie chart model. But basically, I guess the bottom line, how I would describe it today, is that I would still say there are kind of three main contributors to happiness, kind of like three buckets of contributors to happiness. One is our genetics, for sure, you know, that's very powerful. We all know that a psychologist. The second is our life circumstances, you know, and depending on how good or bad they are,
算是重新审视了饼图模型。但基本上，我想说的是，如果用今天的话来总结，我仍然会说幸福有三个主要贡献因素，就像是幸福贡献的三个“桶”。一个是我们的基因，这是肯定的，你知道，这非常强大。作为一个心理学家，我们都知道这一点。第二个是我们的生活环境，你知道的，根据它们是好还是坏，
they're going to influence our happiness more or less, right? So if you're relatively comfortable, you know, moving to a nicer apartment is it going to make you a lot happier. But if you're living in poverty, moving into a nice, safe place, it's got of course make you a lot happier. And the third kind of bucket or contributor to happiness is what we actually can do, you know, the ways that we behave and the ways that we think in our daily life. So I certainly still believe that those are the three main contributors to happiness.
它们或多或少会影响我们的幸福感，对吧？所以，如果你生活相对安逸，你知道的，搬到一个更好的公寓并不会让你感到幸福得多。但是，如果你生活在贫困之中，搬到一个舒适、安全的地方，当然会让你幸福得多。而幸福的第三种“桶”或贡献因素，就是我们实际能做的事情，也就是我们在日常生活中表现和思考的方式。因此，我当然仍然相信这三个是幸福的主要贡献因素。
I just wouldn't put numbers on them. Okay, that makes sense. So for people with happy genes, if you will, with the biological component you mentioned, are they blessed with more endorphins or other brain chemicals that are associated with happiness? We know that the reverse can be true, that there are people who are chronically depressed because they have a chemical imbalance. Yeah, I'm not a neuroscientist, so I can't speak really specifically to this. I think, yeah, if you're kind of born with a set range for happiness, it's higher than
我只是不会给它们贴上具体的数字标签。好的，这说得通。那么对于那些拥有“幸福基因”的人来说，也就是你提到的具有生物学成分的人，他们是否天生拥有更多与幸福相关的内啡肽或其他大脑化学物质？我们知道事实也可能恰恰相反，有些人因为化学物质失衡而长期抑郁。是的，我不是神经科学家，所以我无法对此进行非常具体的说明。我认为，是的，如果你天生带有一个幸福的基准范围，它会比
other people. My guess is that there are many contributors, sort of biological contributors and genetic contributors to that, and probably they have some of that have to do with different levels of neurohormones, whether it's serotonin and dopamine and, you know, all the kind of the usual suspects, or maybe a susceptibility to learning or maintaining good kind of happiness habits. You know, so for some people, sort of, quote, easy to look on the bright side of things, right, sort of be optimistic, express gratitude, you know, be social, sort of extroversion, for example, as a personality trait that has a strong, heritable component, that is very much correlates.
其他人更高。我猜有许多贡献因素，某种程度上是生物学和遗传学方面的贡献因素，可能其中一些与神经激素的不同水平有关，无论是血清素、多巴胺，你知道的，所有这些常见物质，或者可能是对学习或保持良好幸福习惯的易感性。你知道，所以对某些人来说，可以说是“理所当然”地看到事物光明的一面，对吧，有点像保持乐观、表达感激之情、善于社交——例如外向性作为一种具有强大遗传成分的人格特征，它与幸福感高度相关。
with happiness. So people who are happier are also more likely to be extroverted. Anyway, so I guess my answer to the question is that this is all very, very complex. And so we don't really know what the biological sort of contributors are, but there are probably many. How do you define and measure happiness in your research? You're looking at momentary, positive feelings, a general sense of life satisfaction, or is it even more complicated than that? We look at all of those things. And of course, you know, there's sort of the famous kind of idea that, you know, if you can't measure something, you can't change it, right, you can't really study it. So we do, I think it is important to study to start with measurement. You know, happiness is something that's really subjective. You can't,
因此，更快乐的人也更有可能外向。总之，我想我对这个问题的回答是，这一切都非常非常复杂。所以我们并不是真的很清楚生物学上的贡献因素是什么，但可能有很多。在你的研究中，你是如何定义和测量幸福的？你是在寻找短暂的积极感受、对生活的一般满意度，还是比这更复杂？我们研究所有这些方面。当然，你知道，有一个著名的观点，即“如果你无法衡量某件事，你就无法改变它”，对吧，你就无法真正研究它。所以我们确实认为，从测量开始进行研究是很重要的。你知道，幸福是一种非常主观的事情。你不能，
there's no thermometer for happiness. Sorry, so we use self-report as kind of our gold standard. And we really use, you know, multiple measures. So the idea is, I and many researchers in the well-being science, subscribe to Ed Diener's. Edina really founded the field of the of happiness, sort of his idea that there are really two components of happiness. There's a kind of affective emotional component and there's also a cognitive or judgmental component. So the affective component is how often do you experience positive emotions in your daily life? And so to measure that, we ask people, you know, maybe it's by the minute or hour or day or week, you know, how often do you experience joy, curiosity, you know, pride, serenity, enthusiasm, you know, all sort of all the
幸福是没有温度计的。抱歉，所以我们使用自我报告作为我们的黄金标准。我们确实使用了多种测量方法。因此，我和幸福科学领域的许多研究人员一样，都认同埃德·迪纳（Ed Diener）的观点。埃德·迪纳真正开创了幸福研究领域，他认为幸福实际上有两个组成部分。一个是情感（affective）组成部分，另一个是认知（cognitive）或判断组成部分。情感组成部分是你在日常生活中经历积极情绪的频率。为了测量这一点，我们询问人们，也许是按分钟、按小时、按天或按周，你经历快乐、好奇、骄傲、平静、热情等各种积极情绪（以及消极情绪）的频率如何。
different positive emotions and negative emotions as well. But then the cognitive or judgmental component of happiness is basically the sense that your life is good, that you're progressing towards your life goals at a good pace, that you're satisfied with your life. So that's sort of measuring life satisfaction is also important. That's something that's not going to be as likely to change minute to minute, but it certainly could change week to week, month, to month, year to year. Can you really measure happiness in a lab or do you have to have people going about their lives and maybe carrying some sort of a tracker or some way of telling you from minute to minute or hour to hour how they're feeling. I think you could do both. There are certainly
而幸福的认知或判断组成部分，基本上是指这样一种感觉：你的生活很好，你正以良好的步伐朝着生活目标前进，你对自己的生活感到满意。因此，测量生活满意度也很重要。这不是那种每分钟都可能改变的事情，但它肯定会每周、每月、每年发生变化。你真的能在实验室里测量幸福感，还是必须让人们过着他们的生活，也许随身携带某种追踪器，或者用某种方式逐分逐秒或逐小时地告诉你他们的感受？我认为你可以两者兼顾。所有这些测量方法中本身都存在偏差，你知道，就社会赞许性而言，你知道，有些人只是在实验者面前表现得很幸福。我真的很喜欢在人们过着日常生活时来测量幸福感。我认为他们往往会忘记自己正处于一项研究中。因此，也许其中的一些偏差会有所减少。所以，是的，我对此的感受是，就像心理学任何领域的测量一样，永远不会存在完美无缺的科学。总会有涉及某种偏差。但我们能针对这个问题进行越多维度的交叉验证，我们就能用越多不同的方法来测量。比如用追踪器测量，但也
biases inherent in all of these measurements, you know, in terms of how, you know, in terms of social desirability, you know, some people just appear happy to the experimenter. I really like to measure happiness kind of in daily life as people go about their lives. I think they tend to sort of forget they're in a study. And so maybe some of those biases are a little bit reduced. So yeah, I guess the way I feel about it, like with measurement in any area of psychology, that there's always going to be, it's never going to be a perfect kind of perfect science. There's always going to be sort of biases involved. But the more we can triangulate, you know, on this problem, the more different ways we can measure. So like measuring, you know, maybe with the tracker, but also,
可以，你知道，时不时地要求人们真正反思他们的生活。当然，你也可以获得同伴报告。你还可以获得更客观或更多的生物学测量方法。它们没有哪一个比其他的更好。因此，我们试图通过多种测量方法来进行交叉验证。人们在日常生活中可以做些什么来提升他们的幸福感？我是说，通过你的研究，你发现什么方法真正管用？这确实是我毕生致力于研究的问题。我研究幸福已经 36 年了。
you know, everyone wants it a while asking people to really reflect on their lives. You can also, of course, get peer reports. You can also get kind of more objective or more biological measures. None of them are really better than others. So we try to triangulate by having multiple measures. What can people do to boost their happiness on a day-to-day basis? I mean, your research, what have you found that actually works? That's really the question that I've devoted my career to. I've been studying happiness since for 36 years.
所以是从 1989 年开始，不过我想大概是从 1999 年左右开始的。所以在过去的 26 年里，我的实验室开始做我们所谓的“幸福干预”（happiness interventions）。幸福干预基本上就像临床试验，但我们测试的不是新药，而是测试幸福策略或幸福练习。我们专注于研究最多的活动有三种类型。我们做过很多感恩实验。所以这些都是，再次强调，这些都是随机对照试验。我们随机分配一组参与者去表达感激之情，比如在一个月或两个月内，每周写一封感恩信
So it's 1989, but I guess about since basically about 1999. So last 26 years, my lab started doing what we called happiness interventions. And happiness interventions are basically like clinical trials, but instead of testing a new drug, you know, we're testing a happiness strategy or happiness exercise. And there are three types of activities that we focus on studying the most. We've done a lot of gratitude experiments. And so these are all, again, these are all randomized controlled trials. We randomly assign a group of participants to express gratitude, say write a gratitude letter
给你想感谢的任何人，然后我们设立各种对照组，并对人们进行纵向追踪。所以，是的，我们一直在测试的一种幸福策略类别是感恩。另一种是善举。因此，我们要求人们在日常生活或每周生活中做出更多的善举，
to anyone you want once a week for a month or for two months. and then we have various control groups and we follow people across time. So one, yeah, so one kind of category of happiness strategies we've been testing is gratitude. Another is acts of kindness. And so we ask people to do more acts of kindness in their daily life or their weekly life
比他们平时做的要多。我们每天都会为他人做出善举。所以这是我们在超越常规。我们一直关注的第三组活动就是“多社交”，要求人们更加社交，参与更多的社交互动和对话。因此，基本上最核心的
than they would otherwise do. We all do acts of kindness for others every day. So this is we're sort of going over and above. And the third sort of set of activities we've been focusing on is just being, is asking people to be more social, engage in more social interactions and conversations. So basically the bottom,
总结是，如果听众注册了我的新幸福时快讯，我告诉他们的第一件事就是，你知道，我的头号幸福秘诀是什么？每个人都想知道那是什么。因此，在经过 36 年的研究后，我的实验室、我的学生和我自己得出了一条陈词滥调，那就是我们发现，在随机对照试验中几乎所有能让人更快乐的方法之所以奏效，都是因为它们让人感觉到了更多的连接。
online and if listeners sign up to my new happiness newsletter, like the first thing that I tell them is, you know, kind of what is my number one happiness tip? And everyone wants to know what that is. So basically after, you know, 36 years of research, my lab, my students and I have landed on a cliche, which is that what we've discovered is almost everything that works in randomized control trials to make people happier works because it makes them more connected. connected somehow to other people. Although it can be to God or to a pet, right? It doesn't have to be a person.
以某种方式与其他人建立连接。尽管对象也可以是上帝或宠物，对吧？不一定非得是人。它能让人感觉更有连接感。并非所有事情都如此。我的意思是，你可以想象像体育锻炼或冥想，这真的与其他人无关，但即使是那样，即使是冥想和锻炼也经常与他人有关。但在我们的研究中，连接本质上是幸福的关键。所以你能做的任何事情，只要能加强一种关系、加强一种连接，而在最近几年，我和我的实验室开始专注于研究社交互动
It makes people feel more connected. Not everything. I mean, you could imagine like physical exercise or meditation, which really has nothing to do with other people, but even that, even meditation and exercise often has to do with others as well. But in our studies, basically connection is the key to happiness. So anything you can do to strengthen a relationship to strengthen a connection, And in more recent years, my lab and I have started to focus on studying social interactions
和对话。因为我们是如何与生活中的其他人建立连接的呢？在我们的文化中，好吧，我会说你可以通过触觉连接。你可以通过舞蹈连接。有许多方法可以建立连接。但在我们的文化中最常见的连接方式是通过交谈。就像你在这个播客中所做的那样，这只是简单地与他人交谈。我几个月前 actually 做过一个播客，当时主持人说他开始做这个的原因是
and conversations. Because how do we connect to other people in our lives? In our culture, well, I'll say you can connect by touch. You can connect with dance. There's lots of ways to connect. But the most common way in our culture to connect is by talking. It's just simply talking to others like what you're doing in this podcast. I actually did a podcast a few months ago where the host said the reason he started it is
他基本上怀念与生活中的人进行深度的连接。因此他决定找个借口，真正与人们进行某种深度的对话。不管怎样，现在我们正在研究对话。我们正在研究如何进行顺利的对话，什么样的对话能让人更快乐。我们开始研究倾听，你知道的，因为积极的、高质量的倾听是进行真正伟大对话的关键之一。最后，我和我的老同事哈里·里斯（Harry Reis），
that he was missing, basically, deeply connecting to people in his life. And so he decided to have an excuse to really have sort of deep conversations with people. Anyway, so now we're studying conversations. We're studying how to have conversations that go well, which kind of conversations make people happier. We're beginning to study listening, you know, because active, high-quality listening is one of the keys to having a really great conversation. And finally, my longtime colleague, Harry Reese and I,
哈里是罗切斯特大学（University of Rochester）的关系科学家，我们刚刚完成了一本书，叫做《如何感受被爱》（How to Feel Loved）。那本书基本上讲的是如何增强生活中的连接，即社交连接。你刚才提到，不只是人，你还可以对上帝产生连接。你可以对你的宠物产生连接。现在越来越多的 AI 聊天机器人可以成为你的朋友。这是一个好的替代品吗？我是说，与仅仅是技术的东西进行互动，人们真的能因此感受到幸福吗？
Harry is a relationship scientist in the University of Rochester. we just finished a book called How to Feel Loved. And that book is basically about how to increase connection, social connection in your life. So you just mentioned it's not just people you could feel connection to God. You could feel connection to your pets. More and more there are these AI chatbots out there that can be your friend. Is that a good substitute? I mean, can people really feel happiness as a result of interacting with something that is just technology?
这是一个多么有趣的问题啊！我们在新书里有一个关于这个的小节。你知道，人们报告说他们确实感觉与聊天机器人有连接。正如你可能知道的那样，人们甚至报告说爱上了聊天机器人。显而易见的答案是，你知道，这实际上并不是真实人类连接的很好的替代品。另一方面，我认为这要微妙得多。如果你是一个孤独的人或与世隔绝，我认为它可以为你的生活增加价值。所以，我不想成为这样的人。我不想说，让我们，你知道，不要，不允许人们，你知道，与聊天机器人连接，因为确实会发生一些事情，你知道，感觉就像你在进行真正真实的对话，原因与我们在电影中哭泣相同，对吧？我们也会对非真实的东西产生某种真实的感觉，对吧？就像我们看一部电影，我们
You know, such a fun question. We have a little section about this in our new book. You know, people report they really do feel connected to a chatbot. People report even falling in love with chatbots, as you may know. I mean, the obvious answer is, you know, this is not really a great substitute for real human connection. On the other hand, I think it's just so much more nuanced. I think it could be added value to your life if you're a lonely person or you're isolated. So I don't want to be. I don't want to say like let's, you know, not, not allow people to, you know, to connect with chatbots because there is something that happens, you know, feels like you have real authentic conversations for the same reason that we cry at movies, right? We also feel like a real, something real with something that's not real, right? Like we, we see a movie and we, we know it's not real, we know it's actors, and yet we're sort of, our brain fools us to thinking it is for some similar reasons. And even more powerful reasons, I think a chatbot can, we can have a really deep conversation. So I don't know, I think, I think it's a really
知道这不是真的，我们知道那是演员，然而我们某种程度上，我们的大脑欺骗了我们，让我们觉得它是真的，原因有些类似。而且出于更强大的原因，我认为聊天机器人可以，我们可以进行非常深度的对话。所以，我不知道，我认为这是一个非常微妙的问题。说“哦，这太糟糕了，让我们别这么做”很容易。我很想看到这样一个世界：聊天机器人可以补充我们的日常连接，甚至可能帮助我们增加连接。比如它可以成为一个教练，帮助害羞的人，你知道，在他们的日常生活中建立更多的连接，等等，等等。你可以练习如何互动。
nuanced question. And it's easy to say like, oh, it's terrible and let's let's not do this. I would love to see a world where chat bots can can sort of supplement our day-to-day connections and maybe even help us increase it. Like it could be a coach that helps a shy person, you know, have more connection in their everyday life, et cetera, et cetera. You can practice how to interact. Exactly. In your book, the myths of happiness, you challenge the idea that achieving life milestones are guaranteed happiness boosters. You know, the idea that if I just get that promotion or if I get married, I'll be happy.
完全正确。在你的书《幸福的迷思》（The Myths of Happiness）中，你挑战了这样一种观点：实现人生里程碑是获得幸福的保证。你知道，那种认为“只要我得到那个升职或者我结婚了，我就会幸福”的想法。为什么这些里程碑并不总是能带来持久的幸福？我最主要的回答是享乐适应（hedonic adaptation），你知道的，这是一种人类非常擅长的现象，即习惯生活中的任何变化，尤其是积极的变化。
Why do these milestones not always lead to lasting happiness? My biggest answer is hedonic adaptation, you know, which is a phenomenon that humans are great at becoming accustomed to any change in their life, especially positive changes. and I would bring a sort of evolutionary theory into this, you know, that, you know, you could argue that human beings would never make progress if we were sort of really, really happy with our milestones and then kind of like didn't want to achieve anything more, right? We would progress would stall, right? We'd kind of get to that mountain or find that mate or that friend and then we're done, right? Because we're just sort of happy. And yet we're not finished, you know, because every time we achieve a goal, we're happy for a little bit. and then we are kind of, we now have a newer, you know, even bigger goal in mind.
我会把进化论引入其中，你知道的，你可以认为，如果我们对自己的里程碑感到非常非常高兴，然后就不想再取得任何成就了，人类就永远不会取得进步，对吧？进步就会停滞，对吧？我们会到达那座山或找到那个伴侣或那个朋友，然后就结束了，对吧？因为我们只是感到高兴。然而我们还没有完成，你知道，因为每次我们实现一个目标，我们都会高兴一会儿，
So I think that's evolutionarily adaptive. But it has hedonic costs, right? So when we get, you know, we want to get that job, we want to have a baby, we want to have a new boyfriend. We want to get a new car, you know, at first it makes us happy. And it does make us happy. So I don't want to say that those monsters don't make people happy. And sometimes they actually make us durability happy. Marriage can make us durably happy really forever.
然后我们就会有一种更新的、甚至更大的目标在脑海中。所以我想这在进化上是具有适应性的。但它有享乐上的代价，对吧？所以当我们得到，你知道，我们想要得到那份工作，我们想要有个宝宝，我们想要交个新男友。我们想要买辆新车，你知道，起初它让我们快乐。它确实让我们快乐。所以我不打算说那些里程碑不会让人快乐。有时它们确实让我们持久地快乐。婚姻确实能让我们持久地快乐，真的可以永远持续下去。
But there's some amount of. adaptation. I don't think it is almost ever where there's like no adaptation at all. So I moved into an apartment that has a beautiful view. And I think views are something that we don't tend to adapt to as much. Maybe again, for evolutionary reasons, we kind of like to see views of mountains or water. But I have adapted to it. I haven't adapted to it 100%. Maybe I've adapted to it's like 50%. Right. So it's not as like, wow, you know, as the day I moved in. And same thing maybe with a good marriage, right? So you're not as excited, not as passionate the 10th year than the first year. And so, yes, I think Hadatic adaptation is sort of my biggest answer to that.
但也有一定程度的适应。我认为几乎从来没有完全没有适应的情况。所以，我搬进了一套视野极佳的公寓。我认为风景是我们往往不那么容易适应的东西。也许同样出于进化的原因，我们有点喜欢看山或水的风景。但我已经适应了它。我并没有 100% 适应它。也许我适应了大约 50%。对吧。所以它没有像搬进去那天那样让人“哇”地惊叹。对美好的婚姻来说可能也是如此，对吧？所以你不会像第十年那样兴奋，没有第一年那么有激情。所以，是的，我认为享乐适应是我对此最主要的回答。
Why doesn't money make us as happy as we think it will? Well, again, it's the same kind of category where we adapt and we always want more. So lots of reasons. Okay, so one is, well, our social comparisons change, right? So we get that new car and suddenly we're comparing ourselves to people who have even nicer cars. One of my, one of the examples I used from a long time ago is that a friend who, you know, kind of got wealthier and built a mansion. And, and then she started talking about how, like, and she flies first class. And then she started talking about how her friends, her new friends,
为什么金钱不像我们想象的那样能带给我们那么多快乐？好吧，同样地，这是同一类情况，我们会适应，而且我们总是想要更多。所以有很多原因。好吧，一个原因是，我们的社会比较改变了，对吧？所以我们买了那辆新车，突然之间我们开始与那些拥有更好车的人进行比较。我很久以前用过的一个例子是，一个朋友，你知道的，变得更富有并建造了一座豪宅。然后她开始谈论，像，她坐头等舱旅行。然后她开始谈论她的朋友们，她的新朋友们，
they have private jets. And so suddenly she was unhappy because she was flying first class, but they were flying in a private, they were going private. So there's always someone who's better off than you are always. Even when you think about, you know, sort of the richest person imaginable, there's always someone that they can say, oh, but, you know, whatever, their view is a little bit nicer than my view. Anyway, so we always, we always sort of want more. And again, maybe that's adaptive, though we always want more because that promotes progress. Yeah, so we're getting back to money. There's actually a lot of nuances about money. One of my favorite recent findings is that money does make people happier, but only if you're a happy person to begin with. So happy people,
他们拥有私人飞机。所以突然之间她不高兴了，因为她坐的是头等舱，而他们坐的是私人飞机。总会有人的情况比你好，总是如此。即使当你想到，你知道的，可以说是你能想象到的最富有的人，总是会有人让他们说：“哦，但是，你知道，无论如何，他们的风景比我的风景好一点点。”不管怎样，我们总是，我们总是想要更多。而且再次强调，这也许是具有适应性的，尽管我们总是想要更多，因为这能促进进步。
who make more money are happier when they make more money. But unhappy people are kind of not that happy when they make more money. And then, of course, the other answer is it depends how you spend it, right? So if you spend your money on, and the nice way to think about it, sort of three basic needs that we have for connection, autonomy, and competence, or for personal growth connection and, you know, contributing to the world, if you spend your money in ways that contribute to those basic needs, then people are happier, right?
是的，所以我们回到金钱上来。关于金钱其实有很多微妙之处。我最喜欢的最新发现之一是：金钱确实能让人更快乐，但前提是你本来就是一个快乐的人。所以快乐的人，如果赚到更多的钱，当他们赚到更多的钱时会更快乐。而不快乐的人在赚到更多钱时其实并没有那么快乐。然后，当然，另一个答案是这取决于你是如何花钱的，对吧？所以如果你把钱花在……很好的一种思考方式是，我们对连接、自主和胜任力的三项基本需求，或者为了个人成长、连接和（对世界的贡献），如果你把钱花在有助于满足这些基本需求的方式上，那么人们就会更快乐，对吧？
So if you spend your money on philanthropy, helping others, or taking out your nephew to the zoo and you spend your money on personal growth, learning a new language, you know, traveling, you know, doing something, learning something new, and you spend your money in connection, right, taking out your friends to dinner or something like that, then that makes you happy. But if you spend your money on possessions, material things that you just put in the closet or the garage or on your shelf, we tend to adapt to those things so that that doesn't make us happier. We just want more. We're going to take a short break. And when we return, we'll talk to Dr. Lubal-Merson. about a new report that funds young people are less happy than they used to be and why that might be. Make every get-together chill. This Memorial Day get up to an extra $1,000 off select top brand appliances like LG. Plus, get free delivery at the Home Depot. Tackle pool towels and camp laundry with a large capacity washer.
所以如果你把钱花在慈善事业上、帮助他人、带你的侄子去动物园，或者你把钱花在个人成长上、学习一门新语言、旅行、做某事、学习新东西，并且你把钱花在连接上，比如带你的朋友去吃晚饭或类似的事情，那么这会让你快乐。但如果你把钱花在占有欲上，花在那些你只是放进衣橱、车库或书架的物质东西上，我们往往会适应这些东西，所以这并不会让我们更快乐。我们只是想要更多。我们要稍事休息。回来后，我们将与柳博米尔斯基博士交谈，
And host and style with the fridge serving craft ice, mini craft ice, cube dice, and crushed ice. Shop appliance savings now through June 3rd at the Home Depot. Depot. Offer valid May 14th through June 3rd, U.S. only. Free delivery on appliance purchases of $998 or more. The C store online for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton,
讨论一份新报告，该报告发现年轻人不如过去快乐，以及这其中的原因可能是什么。让每次聚会都轻松惬意。这个阵亡将士纪念日，精选顶级品牌电器（如 LG）最高可享额外 1000 美元优惠。此外，在家得宝（The Home Depot）还可享受免费送货服务。用大容量洗衣机轻松搞定泳池毛巾和露营衣物。用配备制冰功能的冰箱招待客人并彰显品味，可制作球形冰块、迷你球形冰块、方冰和碎冰。即日起至 6 月 3 日，快来家得宝选购优惠家电。优惠有效时间为 5 月 14 日至 6 月 3 日，仅限美国。购买 998 美元或以上的家电可享免费送货。详情请查阅实体店或在线了解。
for the stay. Every year, researchers publish something called the World Happiness Report. And this year, the big headline was that in many countries, young adults are less happy than they used to be. Young adulthood used to be a pretty happy time of life on average. Why do you think that might be changing? You know, interestingly, I think one of the reasons, one of the theories the U.S. is dropped out of the top like 20 or top 24 countries is because particularly in the U.S., young people, I think ages 14 to 28 or 14 to 24 are particularly unhappy. Well, you know, one obvious answer is social media and screens and sort of lack of connection. Again, getting back to if social connection is the key to happiness, anyone who has more,
每年，研究人员都会发布一份名为《世界幸福报告》（World Happiness Report）的报告。今年的头条新闻是，在许多国家，年轻成年人不如过去快乐。平均而言，年轻成年期曾经是人生中相当快乐的一段时光。你认为这为什么会发生变化？你知道，有趣的是，我认为原因之一——美国掉出前 20 名或前 24 名国家行列的理论之一，是因为特别是在美国，年轻人，我认为 14 到 28 岁或 14 到 24 岁的年轻人特别不快乐。
less social connection, greater loneliness is going to be less happy. We know a lot about how starting in whatever is at 2008, you know, with the introduction of the smartphone, with the introduction of the like button on Facebook, young people have been spending more and more time on screens, less and less time, you know, in person with one another. And again, I want to be a little bit more nuanced about this. You know, some people get a lot of connection, you know, through social, you know, through Facebook or whatever, through social media, through texting, through listening to music. So I don't want to just say it's all bad.
嗯，你知道，一个显而易见的答案是社交媒体、屏幕和某种程度上连接的缺失。再次回到如果社交连接是幸福的关键这一论点，任何拥有更多、更少社交连接、更严重孤独感的人都会不快乐。我们对以下情况了解很多：自从——无论是什么时候，是 2008 年随着智能手机的引入，随着 Facebook 上“点赞”按钮的引入——年轻人花在屏幕上的时间越来越多，面对面相处的时间越来越少。再次强调，我想对此表现得更加微妙一些。你知道，有些人通过社交途径，你知道，通过 Facebook 或其他渠道、通过社交媒体、通过发短信、通过听音乐获得了大量的连接。所以我不希望直接说这一切都是不好的。
But that is just kind of an obvious answer to that question that they're sort of spending less and less time in person. You know, and there's data. Gene Twenge has some great data in her book, IGen on how if you compare generations, you know, my generation, you know, basically the, what is it that you've shows that the 12th graders today look like eighth graders in our generation in terms of how much time they spent, you know,
但这只是对该问题的一个显而易见的回答，即他们面对面相处的时间越来越少。你知道，有相关数据。简·特温格（Jean Twenge）在她的书《iGen》中提供了一些很好的数据，展示了如果你比较不同的代际，你知道，我的代际，你知道，基本上是，数据显示今天的 12 年级学生在我们那一代人中看起来就像 8 年级学生，看他们花在
not with their parents, how much time they spend working outside the home, driving and even sort of quote sort of negative things like alcohol sexual behavior you know early sexual behavior they're just doing it all much much later they're just spending a lot less time in person if you look at weekend activity teenagers are it used to be that you were kind of an outcast if you spent the whole weekend sort of alone in your room and now I think I've seen I've seen stats that are something like 50% or even maybe two-thirds sort of don't really like see anyone in person on the weekend outside of school, whereas it used to be that almost everyone did. So anyway, to me, to my mind, that must contribute to the reduced happiness.
不和父母在一起的时间有多少，他们在校外工作、开车甚至做一些所谓的“负面事情”（如饮酒、性行为、过早的性行为）的时间有多少，他们做所有这些事情都要晚得多。他们面对面相处的时间要少得多。如果你看看周末的活动，青少年们……过去，如果你整个周末都独自呆在房间里，你会被认为是个边缘人；而现在，我看到过统计数据，大约 50%，甚至可能是三分之二的人，在周末除了学校之外，实际上并不会面对面见到任何人，而过去几乎每个人都会。无论如何，在我看来，这肯定会导致幸福感的下降。
Eventually, sad things will happen to pretty much everyone. You live long enough. Bad things are going to happen. How do happy people handle negative emotions? Are they different in the way that they cope with things going south? From my understanding, of course, happy people are just as hit by negative, you know, events as unhappy. So I guess if I were to draw kind of it visually, you know, an unhappy, a happy person, it might take a similar hit. And we've even done studies where we give negative feedback
最终，悲伤的事情几乎会发生在每个人身上。只要你活得够久，不好的事情就会发生。快乐的人如何处理负面情绪？他们在应对事情变糟的方式上与其他人不同吗？据我了解，当然，快乐的人受到负面事件打击的程度和不快乐的人是一样的。所以我想如果我用视觉化的方式来描绘，一个不快乐的人和一个快乐的人，可能会受到类似的打击。我们甚至做过这样的实验：给快乐和不快乐的人提供负面反馈，
to happy and unhappy people, and both the types of participants get that hit, you know, whether it's to their sort of self-esteem temporarily or to their mood. But happy people seem to recover faster. So they're basically, essentially, they're more resilient. They kind of bounce back faster.
两类参与者都会受到这种打击，无论是对他们暂时的自尊还是对他们的情绪。但快乐的人似乎恢复得更快。因此，从根本上讲，他们更具韧性。他们反弹得更快。
You know, how they bounce back. I think there's lots of reasons that there's coping strategies that they might use more effectively. Unhappy people tend to ruminate more. I spent 10 years studying rumination, which is sort of dwelling in circles over and over again and sort of how you're feeling and things are not going well.
你知道他们是如何反弹的吗？我认为有很多原因，比如他们可能更有效地使用了应对策略。不快乐的人往往会反刍思考（ruminate）更多。我花了 10 年时间研究反刍思考，这有点像在脑海中一遍又一遍地兜圈子，思考你的感受以及事情进展不顺的情况。
And that creates a vicious cycle, which makes you more anxious, more depressed, more sad, more angry. Whereas, as I mentioned, happy people tend to bounce faster from those negative events. Why study happiness? What got you going down? particular path? For me, it was happiness as like sort of the Holy Grail. You know, most of us,
这会产生一个恶性循环，让你更加焦虑、更加沮丧、更加悲伤、更加愤怒。然而，正如我所提到的，快乐的人往往能更快地从这些负面事件中恢复过来。为什么要研究幸福？是什么促使你走上这条特定的道路？对我来说，幸福就像是圣杯。你知道，我们大多数人，
most people around the world will say that they want to be happy or they want their children to be happy. I'm from the Soviet Union where, and this is actually part of the answer, where people talk about the importance of suffering to build character or to gain salvation into the next life. People aren't happy when they, when you pass them on the street. That is not really the full picture. I think that's sort of a public persona. But I actually did a study a long time ago where I went back to Russia and asked people, what do you want most for your children? And like Americans, Russians basically gave the same answer, which is that they want their children to be happy. So maybe kind of dependent on how you ask the question. Anyway, so I immigrate to the United States
世界上大多数人都会说他们想要快乐，或者他们希望自己的孩子快乐。我来自苏联，在那里——这其实也是答案的一部分——人们谈论苦难对于建立性格或在来世获得救赎的重要性。当你走过街头时，人们看起来并不快乐。这其实并不是全貌。我认为那只是一种公众面具。但我很久以前做过一项研究，我回到俄罗斯问人们：“你对孩子最大的期望是什么？”像美国人一样，俄罗斯人基本上给出了相同的答案，那就是他们希望自己的孩子快乐。所以这也许取决于你如何提出问题。无论如何，我在九岁半时移民到了美国，
when I'm nine and a half years old. And that was the first thing I noticed, the sort of differences in happiness. So I think I was interested from early age, like, why are Americans so much happier than Russians. I met with my college advisor a few years ago after 30 years of not having seen him and he told me that in college that I was interested in happiness. I didn't remember that. He said I talked a lot about happiness because my, and the reason I say this is because the story I've always told myself and others is that it was really serendipitous, the research on happiness. A very first day, I went to Stanford for my PhD. My advisor was Lee Ross, but really, you know, brilliant thinker who was one of the world's experts on conflict and negotiation.
那是注意到的第一件事，即幸福感方面的差异。所以我想我从小就很感兴趣，为什么美国人比俄罗斯人快乐得多。几年前，在三十年没见之后，我见到了我的大学导师，他告诉我，我在上大学时就对幸福感兴趣了。我不记得了。他说我经常谈论幸福，因为我的——我之所以这么说，是因为我一直对自已和他人讲述的故事是，对幸福的研究纯粹是机缘巧合。我去斯坦福读博士的第一天，我的导师是李·罗斯（Lee Ross），但他真的是一位杰出的思想家，是世界冲突与谈判领域的专家之一。
You know, nothing to do with happiness. You could even argue maybe kind of the opposite of happiness. And the very, very first day that I met him, we took a walk around campus and we started talking about happiness. I don't remember who brought it up, you know, it was probably him, but we started asking each other questions like, you know, why are some people happier than others? Kind of the question that you asked, you began the podcast with. You know, what is the secret to happiness?
这与幸福毫无关系。你甚至可以说这有点像幸福的反面。而在我见到他的第一天，我们在校园里散步，我们开始谈论幸福。我不记得是谁挑起这个话题的，你知道，可能时他，但我们开始互相问一些问题，比如：“为什么有些人比其他人更快乐？”这有点像你开始播客时提出的问题。你知道，幸福的秘密是什么？
and that first conversation literally on the very first day of grad school led me to start doing research on happiness. Back then, Ed D.N.R. was really the only person in the field, and he was studying what he called subjective well-being. I didn't know any. There were some books about happiness, but I didn't know anyone else studying it. That was 1989. I understand you've recommended that we do more research into MDMA or ecstasy to understand how it can lead to more social connection and by extension, of course, happiness. Why should we be interested in finding happiness and connection through drugs? Isn't that essentially cheating? So I started studying MDMA because I thought like, wow, this is like perfect substance to study if you're interested in deep connection because it makes people feel deeply connected, deeply understood and loved, and
而那次对话，字面上发生在研究生院的第一天，引导我开始研究幸福。那时，埃德·迪纳（Ed Diener）真的是该领域唯一的人，他研究的是他所谓的“主观幸福感”。我不知道有谁在研究。有一些关于幸福的书，但我不知道还有谁在研究它。那是 1989 年。据我了解，你曾建议我们应该对 MDMA（摇头丸）进行更多研究，以了解它如何能带来更多的社交连接，当然，进而带来幸福。我们为什么要对通过药物寻找幸福和连接感兴趣呢？这本质上不是作弊吗？所以我开始研究 MDMA，因为我想：“哇，如果你对深度连接感兴趣，这是一个完美的物质来研究，”因为它让人感到深深的连接、深深的被理解和被爱，
then you make, and you're grateful and you're trusting and you feel, you see beauty. You see beautiful. in other people and in sort of in everything. And so I thought, I thought it was really for two reasons. Do you want to study MDMA? One is, and it's interesting, the MAPS conference right now is going on in Denver today is the last day, and this is a big conference where psychedelics and all of the substances
然后你就会，你会心存感激、充满信任并且感到快乐，你看到了美。你在其他人以及一切事物中看到了美。所以我想，我想要研究 MDMA 有两个原因。其一是——有趣的是——今天在丹佛举行的 MAPS 会议今天是最后一天，这是一个大型会议，人们在会上讨论迷幻药和所有这些物质。所以其中一个原因是我认为它可以为深度连接的研究提供一个窗口。在实验室里操纵这一点真的非常非常困难。你怎么能让一个参与者在长达一个半小时的时间里，对某人产生真正非常非常深度的连接呢？而使用这种物质有点像，再次强调，它是一种捷径或窗口。所以这个想法是，你可以让人感受到深深的连接，我们在实验室里确实做到了这一点。我在芝加哥大学（University of
are being discussed. So the one reason is I think it could provide a window into the study of deep connection. It's really, really hard to manipulate that in the lab. How do you, for an hour and a half an hour of get a participant to feel really, really deeply connected to someone. And using that substance as kind of like, again, it's sort of a shortcut or a window. So the idea is that you get people to feel deeply connected, which we have actually in the lab. I have a collaborator in University of
Chicago）有一个合作者，我们在那里给参与者提供 MDMA 或对照物质。我们做过一项研究，给一些参与者服用甲基苯丙胺作为对照，因为有趣的是，这实际上是 MDMA 的一个很好的对照。它们都含有安非他命成分。然后你可以观察——再次说明，我不是神经科学家——但你可以观察到当你产生深深的连接时，大脑中被激活的神经通路，你可以观察到正在起作用的心理机制，这可能会，是的，作为一名基础科学家，这可能具有极大的启示意义。但同时，我认为它也可以被使用——再次说明，我不是临床医生——但我认为 MDMA 可以
Chicago where we give people either MDMA or a control substance. We did a study where we gave some participants methamphetamine as a control, because it's actually interestingly a good control to MDMA. Both of them have anphetamine components. And then you can look at, again, I'm not a neuroscientist, but you can look at the brain pathways that are involved when you're, that are sort of activated, when you're feeling deeply connected, you can look at sort of psychological mechanisms that are operating and that could, yeah, that could be, as a basic scientist, that could be really revealing. But also, I think it could be used, and again, I'm not a clinician, but I think MDMA could
芝加哥，我们在那里给人们服用MDMA或对照物质。我们做过一项研究，给一些参与者服用甲基苯丙胺作为对照，因为有趣的是，它实际上是MDMA的一个很好的对照。两者都含有苯丙胺成分。然后你可以观察——再说一次，我不是神经科学家——但你可以观察当你感到深度连结时，大脑中涉及的、被激活的神经通路，你可以观察正在起作用的心理机制，作为一名基础科学家，这可能会非常有启发性。但我也认为它可以被使用，再说一次，我不是临床医生，但我认为MDMA可以
be used sort of clinically or therapeutically. and not like a something that you would necessarily take, you know, once a week or once a month. It's possible that say you're someone who's lonely and has like never really felt deeply connected and you take that substance once and you suddenly realize like, wow, this is something that's possible or you have some insights into your relationships. So maybe you only take it once, you know, or maybe you only take it several times. And just as you know, there's a sort of resurgence of psychedelic science where people are studying both neurosurface, scientists and psychologists, clinical psychologists are studying the usefulness of all kinds of
在临床或治疗上使用。它不像那种你可能必须每周或每月服用一次的东西。可能你是那种感到孤独、从未真正感受到深度连接的人，你服用了一次这种物质，突然意识到，哇，这是可能的，或者你对自己的关系有了某种洞察。所以也许你只服用一次，你知道，或者也许你只服用几次。就像你知道的那样，现在心理学科学正在复兴，神经科学家和心理学家、临床心理学家都在研究各种各样的用途
substances, psychoactive substances. At MDMA, I think, is one that's a really, really interesting one. It has not shown to have many harms. There's certainly, I mean, I would argue, I would very forcefully argue that something like alcohol is much more toxic and harmful than MDMA. It just happens to be legal. MDMA happens to be right now and schedule one. Anyway, I think it's a fascinating topic to study. Are you only looking at MDMA? I mean, I've talked to psychologists for who are studying psilocybin, and they feel like you can have these experiences that will actually persist for very long times and maybe even for a lifetime. Are you seeing that with MDMA? So fascinating. I personally have not studied psilocybin. Some of these other psychedelics,
物质，精神活性物质。我认为MDMA是一个非常非常有趣的例子。它没有显示出太多的危害。当然，我的意思是，我会非常强力地主张，像酒精这样的东西比MDMA毒性大得多，危害大得多。它恰好是合法的。而MDMA现在恰好是美联邦管制的一级药物。无论如何，我认为这是一个非常引人入胜的研究课题。你只研究MDMA吗？我的意思是，我曾和研究裸盖菇素的心理学家交谈过，他们觉得你可以获得这些体验，这些体验实际上可以持续很长时间，甚至可能是一生。你在MDMA上也看到了这一点吗？太迷人了。我个人没有研究过裸盖菇素。其他的一些迷幻药，
yes, they produce a feeling of a connection often, sometimes with an individual. I'm really more interested in studying relationships with particular like other individuals in your life and not necessarily sort of grand sense of connection with kind of all living beings or you know sort of all of you know all of all of earth or the whole universe i mean i think that's really fascinating a study that's just not that's just not my particularly area um i think md may again we have we need to do more studies but i do think it has the potential to have lasting effects certainly people report that have taken mdemea even a few times has changed their lives has made them into a more um yeah like in a more loving person and to someone who Satan has given up on small talk and only, only has deep conversations
是的，它们通常会产生一种连接感，有时是与某个个体的连接。我其实更感兴趣的是研究与你生活中特定个体的关系，而不一定是那种与所有生命形式、地球上的所有人或者整个宇宙的宏大连接感。我的意思是，我认为那是一个非常迷人的研究课题，只是那不是我特别关注的领域。嗯，我认为MDMA，我们同样需要做更多的研究，但我确实认为它有可能产生持久的影响。当然，那些服用过MDMA几次的人报告说，这改变了他们的生活，使他们变得更加，嗯，就像一个更有爱心的人，变成了一个不再沉迷于闲聊、只和别人进行深度对话的人。
with people. What happens with MDMA is that your walls come down. And so one way to think about all of society is that we're kind of all walking around with a wall around us. And we really don't share very much. You know, we don't take off those walls very easily. And I think the world would be a better place if some of those walls came down. You know, there's a lot of emphasis, I think, in American culture around being happy. It's sort of an expectation. The American dream involves ultimately being happy. Is it possible for people to worry too much about being happy and then making yourself unhappy by the constant worrying about I'm not happy enough? Absolutely. And there's really great work by Iris Mouse and June Gruber that are showing how like when people are too preoccupied with
服用MDMA时，你的防备会卸下。因此，看待整个社会的一种方式是，我们所有人走来走去时，周围都筑起了一道墙。我们其实分享得并不多。你知道，我们不会轻易卸下这些防备。我认为，如果其中一些墙能倒塌，世界会变得更美好。你知道，在美式文化中，人们非常强调要快乐。这简直成了一种期望。美国梦最终包含的就是快乐。人们会不会过于担心快乐，然后因为不断担心“我不够快乐”而让自己变得不快乐？绝对会。Iris Mauss和June Gruber做出了非常棒的研究，展示了当人们过于全神贯注于
happiness, that that can backfire. And there's lots of reasons for that, right? So if you're constantly monitoring your happiness, right? It's kind of like when you're trying to lose weight and you're constantly measuring, you know, weighing yourself, or if you're constantly looking at the stock market, right? You don't want to look every hour because it's going to go up and down. So if you're constantly asking yourself, am I happy yet? Am I happy yet? Am I happy yet? Right? That is going to backfire. If you're too focused on the end goal, this sounds like so hokey. But if you're too focused on the end goal, as opposed to being focused on the journey to get there, right? That can sort of backfire and lead you to be dissatisfied. Yeah, if you're if you're standard for happiness is too high,
快乐时，结果可能会适得其反。这有很多原因，对吧？如果你一直在监测自己的快乐，对吧？这就好比你想减肥，然后一直不停地称体重；或者如果你一直在盯着股市，对吧？你不会想每隔一小时就查看一次，因为它会上涨下跌。所以如果你一直在问自己：我快乐了吗？我快乐了吗？我快乐了吗？对吧？这会适得其反。如果你太专注于最终目标，这听起来真的很老套。但如果你太专注于最终目标，而不是专注于实现目标的旅程，对吧？那可能会适得其反，导致你不满意。是的，如果你对快乐的标准太高，
right, you're going to be disappointed if you don't reach that standard. And really, like, what the things that make you happy are not like focusing on happiness, but it's sort of focusing on something else that's going to lead to happiness, right, whether it's, you know, connecting to other people, expressing gratitude, doing acts of kindness, you know, meditating, savoring, you know, whatever, you know, following, you know, following really significant life goals. Like that's really what makes you happy and sort of focusing too much. And again, on the end goal might backfire. It might make it too much of an extrinsic goal, right?
对吧，如果你达不到那个标准，你就会感到失望。实际上，真正让你快乐的事情不是专注于快乐，而是专注于其他会带来快乐的事情，对吧？无论是与他人建立联系、表达感激、行善、冥想、细细品味，还是追求真正有意义的生活目标。这才是真正让你快乐的事情，而过于关注最终目标可能会适得其反。它可能会让它变成一个太强的外在目标，对吧？
Sort of, I'm only doing this. I'm only being kind to you because I want to make you happy. And I heard that this makes you, they'll make you happy. And so, yeah, I'm not a big fan of sort of too much of an obsession or preoccupation with happiness. So what's left to study? You've obviously been looking at happiness for many years, as you've said. What are the big questions that remain to be answered?
某种程度上，“我这样做只是因为我想让你快乐，我听说这会让你快乐”。所以，是的，我不太喜欢对快乐有太多的执念或全神贯注。那么，还有什么好研究的呢？正如你所说，你显然已经研究快乐很多年了。还有哪些重大问题亟待解答？
I guess lots of big questions, including the neuroscience of happiness, which some people are studying. One major project I'm involved with, with Liz Dunn at UBC and others are sort of heading is a mega study that is looking at, you know, sort of giant happiness interventions across all cultures because all these studies that we've been talking about are generally small studies. I mean, not necessarily tiny, but there, you know, we need, we need replicability. We need to be confident in the findings. We need to look at sort of cross-cultural differences to see if these are sort of universal type of happiness strategies or they're, I mean, we already know that there are, some of them do look different in different cultures.
我想有很多重大问题，包括快乐的神经科学，这也是一些人正在研究的。我参与的一个主要项目，是由英属哥伦比亚大学（UBC）的Liz Dunn等人牵头的巨型研究，该研究旨在跨所有文化研究巨型快乐干预措施，因为我们一直在谈论的所有这些研究通常都是小型研究。我的意思是，不一定是极小的，但你知道，我们需要，我们需要可重复性。我们需要对研究结果有信心。我们需要研究跨文化的差异，看看这些是通用的快乐策略，还是——我的意思是，我们已经知道，有些策略在不同的文化中确实看起来有所不同。
And so that's, that's a huge goal and huge project that's, you know, probably going to take, you know, quite a few years to accomplish kind of sort of these sort of mega, I think these mega studies are really important to accomplish in our future. And then, you know, you mentioned, you know, Chad bots. I mean, AI is going to change. change everyone's life, you know, maybe a lot sooner than most people think. And so, you know, can we, can we harness that technology to promote happiness to promote flourishing as opposed to
所以这是一个巨大的目标和巨大的项目，可能需要相当多的时间才能完成。我认为这些巨型研究对于我们的未来非常重要。然后，你知道，你提到了聊天机器人。我的意思是，人工智能将改变每个人的生活，你知道，也许比大多数人想象的要快得多。所以，你知道，我们能否利用这项技术来促进快乐，促进繁荣，而不是
sort of create a dystopian reality that some people are worried that are going to happen? So that is what I'm thinking about a lot these days, sort of in the future, sort of how do we, yeah, how do we leverage AI technology to make sure that it makes people happier as opposed to less happy. Well, Dr. Liebermirsky, I want to thank you for joining me today. It's been very interesting. Thank you. I love these questions. It's been a pleasure to speak to you today. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
创造一些人所担心会发生的反乌托邦现实？这就是我这些天经常思考的问题，关于未来，我们如何，是的，我们如何利用人工智能技术来确保它让人们更快乐，而不是更不快乐。好的，柳博米尔斯基博士，我想感谢你今天能来参加节目。这非常有趣。谢谢你。我喜欢这些问题。今天很高兴能与你交谈。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在苹果、Spotify、YouTube 或任何您获取播客的平台上收听《心理学谈话》过往的节目。如果您对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。
Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shopping this week. We start with only the freshest items, then review your list and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver it in as little as 30 minutes, so you can feel confident it's what you ordered. Fresh groceries, your way, with Ralph's delivery and pickup. And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order. Ralph's, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。代表美国心理学协会，我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。放松身心，让拉尔夫超市（Ralphs）配送服务为您本周的杂货采购效劳。我们从最新鲜的商品开始，然后核对您的清单并仔细挑选每一件。接着，我们将其全部打包，并在短短30分钟内送达，让您确信这就是您所订购的。新鲜杂货，随心所欲，尽在拉尔夫超市配送与自提服务。现在，您的第一笔配送或自提订单还可以节省20美元。拉尔夫超市，为每个人保持新鲜。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。